[Music]
japanese food is amazing in that it's so
simple
it is made up of so many little dishes
that it feels like
little tiny gifts while you're eating
when i'm not in the kitchen i feel very
self-conscious
about how to express who i am as a
person
when i really want to express something
it's so easy to
do it through the medium of food
kaiseki has such a long history but
recognizing that we've decided to do a
modern version of kaiseki
because traditional places in japanese
history
do not necessarily have space for women
my definition of modern kaiseki is
taking traditional kaiseki and
incorporating it with new ideas
but always remembering the core
philosophy which is honor the ingredient
be grateful and do the best to showcase
those ingredients
i'm niki nakayama and this is my master
class
[Music]
i'm looking forward to showing you how
to fabricate some fish
how to steam a dish how to make dashi
the foundation of all japanese cuisine
this is carol
my wife at home and my partner at work
and we're going to talk about
different japanese cooking techniques
and how you can enjoy it as a family or
as
individual dishes i'm going to show you
this very simple
process of washing rice letting it sit
and rest for at least 20 to 30 minutes
is key to
a really beautiful batch of rice we'll
be teaching you
how to cut some sashimi how to make some
tempura and how to grill over binchotan
it looks so beautiful so welcoming and
there's so much life to it
as you're learning these techniques be
kind to yourself let yourself
do things that don't always work but
always learn from them
what i hope people who cook try to
communicate when they make a meal
is a feeling of love and appreciation
i think it's such an expression of
giving and it's such an expression of
care that is what i love most about food
nakayama nikita
[Music]
masterclass
[Music]
you